that brings me back to you bring you
bring up Georgia that brings me to one
of the main points I wanted to ask you
about was Odessa uh which was something
happened in Odessa
after my dawn after Crimea right yeah
um it was armed groups from my Don
showed up and they burned a building
killing 15. the trade Union headquarters
much more than 15 people they they
weren't Russians they were they were
pro-russian right they were the pro you
know there was there was uh kind of but
uh that that was a very complex complex
event and those the significance of
Odessa by the way of that region
world's biggest Ukrainian Port right
surrounded by water
well not surrounded by water but it's on
the water okay
and uh the the burning of the Trade
union building I mean that was that was
that it's one of the things that hasn't
been fully investigated to my
satisfaction but it appears that it was
the pro-russian elements that got that
started the the confrontation and then
both sides got out of hand
um
but I wouldn't uh
um
that was used by Russian propaganda to
recruit people for the war in eastern
Ukraine the the the and the the trip but
the the Russian press coverage cannot be
taken at face value because they were
that in fact they may have it may have
even been a deliberate Russian so
provocation I think on the one of the
Ukrainian the Ukrainian nationalists uh
there's the one of those Neo-Nazi
militias they celebrated this on their
website that none of their groups no one
died on their side it was all well
they're capable of anything I mean there
were Ukrainian uh Pro ukrainians who did
die
uh
and shots were fired when you know there
were two groups the police the the big
mystery about the Odessa events when the
Tre and the the fire in the trade Union
Building
was why the police didn't intervene
why not I mean what what was going on I
have not seen the satisfactory answered
right but I think that uh you know you
we have to look you know there's in
these with these countries
there can be a lot of provocations in
both directions you know on on all sides
but you we have you know we need to look
at the broad the the big big picture
here
the big picture is this
that Ukraine is an independent country
that it had free elections that power
changed hands
parashanko lost the election he gave up
power
a new
president became
uh became the nation's leader as a
result of a democratic election you
don't see that in Russia right
and also that uh it's up to the
Ukrainian people to decide you know who
they belong you know what their nation
is not for the Russians to decide that
so if Russia says that Ukraine is part
of Russia uh that's wonderful that they
have that opinion but that that's a
decision that they can't make right and
uh at the same time an unprovoked uh
Invasion against a country which for all
its faults
is nonetheless Democratic and moving in
the direction of Western ideals by a
country that is uh ruled really by
people who still have the psychology of
the Communists and the Soviet Union and
who have no respect for human life their
the lives of Russian soldiers or of
ukrainians talking about the people
invading currently yeah I mean there's
just no question I mean you know as far
as as uh where where right exists in
this well a lot of these people that are
invading currently they're just kids
right they don't even know what they're
doing or why that's absolutely true
and they're being slaughtered in the
thousands and many don't want to be
there
and they and they and in violation of
all rules because under the under the uh
you know you cannot under the the law in
Russia you cannot send draftees into a
war zone and they're sending them there
with little or no training
right after they were drafted right get
that microphone right under your or you
scoot that way yeah I'm sorry
yeah
um I want to go back real real quick so
so in Odessa yo the guy who became the
president of Odessa was from Georgia
right well he wasn't the president of
Odessa he was the the governor the
governor right yeah that was the former
that was uh
sakashvili who is the uh former uh
leader of Georgia yeah right and uh he
worked closely with the United States
there's many photos of him with George
Bush he also worked for a New York law
firm who represented an NGO
and then
um there's also been he this guy even
who's now the governor of Odessa
he's posted on his Facebook page that he
gets paid the two hundred thousand
dollars a year by the US government
which is more than the governor of Maine
so again things like this just raise all
these questions like why is the US
government paying the governor of Odessa
two hundred thousand dollars a year well
I think in the case of of uh I mean I I
don't I don't know the situation so I
can't answer
but I think that when things like that
uh uh surface when questions surface uh
you know on what basis you know if if
the government is doing it there's a
record of it and uh
and that I mean that in itself is is a
is an important thing we have public
accountability in this country
and I think it rather than just
repeating things that whose significance
we don't understand I would I would
treat it as a question and just say well
what's the Expo you know and seek the
answer right
um if there's if there's something wrong
with it it can you know our in our
system it can be corrected well it just
kind of like it just makes me question
the
and it makes me question Putin Putin's
motives
right if you see like for you have to
forgive my ignorance of the history I
can only watch so many documentaries and
read so many articles but when I see
things like this like like Odessa
essentially becoming a united state in
the U.S run by a gun no that didn't
happen and and and he's not Governor
anymore he's not Governor anymore okay
no and I mean oh
and this is you know we we exist in the
um
in the era
of
bad information
when I was
Young
that's a long time ago
there were only a handful of people who
were entitled to an opinion and these
were the columnists the leading National
columnists who wrote
for the big newspapers Walter lippman
James Reston Joe allsop they had an
opinion they could express it
everybody else could vote or they could
you know Express their opinions to their
friends and families within the wall
Four Walls of their homes or the homes
of other people
then later the the the area of you know
the possibilities expanded there began
to be op-ed pages
where you know more people could express
an opinion that would get read
and discussed
and then uh but but with the internet
now
uh everybody has an opinion
or if they want to and we we have
something we just didn't have before
somebody says something stupid and
that's a major news event and then
somebody says something it's even more
stupid in answer to the first stupid
remark and you've got a Continuing Story
uh as we without
you know in a previous year and none of
that would be considered newsworthy
the you know the dumb remarks that
people make so we so we're now we have a
a great expansion
of the amount of opinion and information
that's circulating
but uh
it hasn't led to our being you know kind
of more enlightened on the contrary it's
just led to greater and greater
confusion and mutual abuse
foreign